ah yes is are we pissed are we pissed
off what by the way the world is divided
with the [ __ ] our real uh swimmy girl
what the [ __ ] is it
Little Mermaid Ariel swimming girl and
um
she's black now which I don't give a
[ __ ] I don't care she's not real make
her [ __ ] make her a [ __ ] chair I
don't give a [ __ ] like it doesn't bother
me at all all right and so Arielle is
black they made her black still gave her
red hair weird she's not Eve
you know
so uh and now this is hilarious so
people are mad you know they think it's
stupid that it's like how do you [ __ ]
up like feels about the sanctity of
Disney like we don't give a [ __ ] go [ __ ]
yourself you know they get rid of their
pride colors the [ __ ] second the
clock hits Midnight at the end of that
month what is it June July I don't know
and um
pride month and so
um
yeah Tinkerbell flies across and does
the [ __ ] Disney swirl to second that
[ __ ] hits the end of pride month uh
midnight Tinkerbell goes yeah well [ __ ]
dude it just [ __ ] flies away
whenever they shouldn't marry [ __ ] it
and just flies away
ends yeah right
and so uh
yeah like Disney gives a [ __ ] so there
so Arielle is black now and um I could
give a rat's ass
but people are mad because they think
like you know they're [ __ ] up history
literally you know I I assume a lot of
these people are are white
uh because Arielle was drawn originally
White
which also has no legs so she's not real
she's got a fin instead of legs so
anyway pipe down but I don't give a [ __ ]
is it is it is it annoying the reason
yes the reason why it's annoying is
because you know Disney doesn't give a
[ __ ] about it but they're doing it
because they think that affects it
affects our bottom line and so here's
the deal so they made her black which
fine I give a [ __ ] like I said but now
people are mad at that and and woke
quote unquote people are mad that they
photoshopped
the black girl
and she doesn't seem as black
so
they lose again
my point is you can't ever be woke
enough this movement makes people uh
they eat their own so you can't win so
just from now on every Disney character
white it doesn't matter what the [ __ ]
white and I'm talking about
like The Cricket in Pinocchio now he's
white okay the trolls they're all white
I know they were pink and blue and [ __ ]
[ __ ] white dude this way you don't
get to be mad if oh well that one is
obviously the black one because of the
way it talks and he has a backwards hat
on or Jar Jar Binks he is white
you know
me so privileged
and so
but I just think it's [ __ ]
you just can't win dude so just like who
you know
this whole world [ __ ]
I don't know
what it doesn't matter what am I I'm the
old guy now or whatever
Ariel's black I think that she should be
black I think that everyone in that
movie should be black and I think that
it should be literally
the blackest movie I've ever [ __ ]
seen
crazy crazy crazy crazy
crazy crazy
[Music]